all right listen how about this how
about I'm gonna make a statement and if
it's a true statement and you don't have
to correct me is what Michael has
incurable okay that's a question you
can't guess if I should be saving and
then so my statement is what Michael has
is incurable that's it so I'm thinking
before it gets bad I want to end it
I don't want change things you know I'll
make some pizzas
wanna play some patent
[Music]
they had a whole process that they give
you the pills you can take but I don't
want to do it alone and I was hoping you
would help me out
[Music]
what
don't don't drop it the places where you
could fulfill the prescription there's
six hours yes we're gonna do a little
road trip
[Music]
where's Jason oh we live on a guest here
thanks again out we're drinking our
urine you get from running out of gas
the next step is drinking here
[Applause]
fastest land animal forty miles an hour
the cheetah goes 60 or 65
you had to live like this
you could adapt this is how bees see
no good are you Intel
can coop up miracles happen
[Music]
you know sir
you
[Music]
you